während das ganze land und auch andere
länder schon lange über den flughafen im
süden der stadt sprechen der ein ums
andere jahr nicht eröffnet werden kann
weil die brandschutzvorrichtungen nicht
funktionieren gibt es hier hinter mir
beim bundestag im
marie-elisabeth-lüders-haus das
gegenteilige problem wasser im keller
grund ist bodenplatte hat risse das
gleich neben der spree kann sich auch
der laie vorstellen ist ein ziemlich
großes problem
doch wie das so ist bei großprojekten
kommen neue probleme im laufe der
verzögerung und diesmal kommen sie aus
brüssel die eingebaute heizungs und
belüftungsanlage entspricht nicht mehr
den normen wie sie haben muss also auch
hier muss umgebaut werden
ein mann weist sehr viel über den
erweiterungsbau des
marie-elisabeth-lüders-hauses das ist
der fdp-politiker wolfgang kubicki
er ist nicht nur vizepräsident des
deutschen bundestages sondern auch
vorsitzender der baukommission ihn will
ich jetzt befragen
[Musik]
herr kubicki kann der erweiterungsbau
des marie-elisabeth-lüders-hauses noch
fertig werden und wenn ja wann
also ich gehe davon aus dass da fertig
werden kann und sie mitgeteilt worden
dass wir darüber erkenntnisse bekommen
zu beginn der zweiten jahreshälfte
diesen jahres auch da ist das bba
optimistisch den terminplan halten zu
können allerdings nach meinen
erfahrungen der vergangenheit würde ich
nicht darauf wetten dass wir 20 21
einziehen können darauf würden sie den
wetten
spätestens zum ende der nächsten
legislaturperiode als 20 25 dürfte es
soweit sein wenn sie im groben etwas
sagen zu den mehrkosten die gegenüber
der ursprünglichen planung entstehen die
verzögerung sei 2015 kostet dem
steuerzahler
30 40 mio eur das haben wir die idee
bauvorhaben der bundesregierung künftig
in eine eine private firma zu übergeben
wäre das denn für den das
marie-elisabeth-lüders-haus auch noch
möglich nein das wäre zu spät das ist ja
ein projekt was läuft aber wir haben
eine ganze reihe von neubaumaßnahmen
beim lesen blog post und fliesen block
west durchzuführen alle baulichkeiten
bei denen wir uns befinden jetzt hier
des reichstages sind zwischen 1903 und
1998 durch an der private gmbh im besitz
des bundes gebaut wurde das innerhalb
von fünf jahren war es möglich diese
ganz einfach komplett komplexe
herzustellen
eine solche gmbh hat den vorteil dass
sich nun um diese projekte kümmert
nichts anderes nebenbei macht ich
plädiere dafür aus geschwindigkeits
gründen hier ist es sonst relativ egal
dass man dies konzentriert und in einer
gesellschaft im besitz des bundes
durchführt vielen dank
ja der streit um das
marie-elisabeth-lüders-haus ist das
haben wir von einem kubicki erfahren
nicht nur ein streit um risse im boden
platten und feuchte keller sondern es
ein streit darum wer solche großprojekte
eigentlich bauen kann besser der staat
oder besser ein privatunternehmen für
das lüders haus ist es zu spät das
bleibt in staatlicher regie und wenn
denn die optimisten recht behalten
werden tatsächlich 2021 oder vielleicht
ein jährchen oder zwei später dort auch
endlich die abgeordneten einziehen die
das eigentlich schon vor jahren hätten
tun sollen